[Música]
Bienvenidos a enlace andino desde
Venezuela en este programa hablaremos
sobre la oposición venezolana luego que
un grupo opositores decidiera votar por
la eliminación del gobierno interino que
Durante los últimos cuatro años presidió
Juan guaidó y veremos Cuál es el
escenario actual de Caro unas elecciones
presidenciales Por otra parte
analizaremos cómo este giro favorece a
Nicolás Maduro quien el último año ha
sido fortalecido tras los cambios en la
geopolítica mundial
[Música]
el pasado 30 de diciembre un grupo de
diputados de la oposición electos en el
año 2015 decidió por votación
mayoritaria retirarle el apoyo a Juan
guaidó como presidente interino de
Venezuela y eliminar esa figura de forma
definitiva el debate que fue transmitido
en redes sociales dejó en evidencia las
profundas fracturas en el seno de la
oposición hemos tenido un presidente de
la asamblea nacional que poniendo en
duda la separación de poderes ha
ejercido al mismo tiempo la presidencia
de la asamblea y la presidencia
encargada
hemos tenido un gobierno interino que
tenía fecha de caducidad y carácter
transitorio nadie compra los treinta
días pero tampoco cuatro años y lo que
era algo provisional se convirtió en
Perpetuo cuatro años el interinato que
presidía Juan guaidó se encontró la lo
interno de Venezuela prácticamente se
sostenía el respaldo del gobierno
estadounidense el manejo de los activos
en el exterior y la posibilidad de
negociar el levantamiento de las
sanciones impuestas por Estados Unidos y
Europa la principal preocupación para
quienes querían mantener el gobierno
interino era qué pasaría con esos
activos y qué tristeza que ahorita
quiera meter en la puerta diciendo que
es que si se pierda el oro es culpa de
Inglaterra no me jodan chico eso no es
así si se pierde el oro
Nicolás Maduro recupera eso es
precisamente por la irresponsabilidad de
no haber querido construir resolución
consensuada a tiempo
Estados Unidos resolvió respaldar la
decisión Del parlamento electo en 2015 y
autorizar a las comisiones designadas
para el manejo de los recursos en sidco
la respuesta del gobierno de maduro fue
meter órdenes de captura contra la nueva
directiva compuesta por tres exdiputadas
actualmente en el exilio a la fecha los
principales líderes opositores no han
logrado ponerse de acuerdo en la
estrategia para llegar a la presidencia
de Venezuela analistas coinciden que el
principal reto para la oposición este
2023 será recuperar legitimidad y lograr
unas primarias para elegir un candidato
único que enfrenta Nicolás Maduro en los
comicios presidenciales previstos para
2024 no hay hoy en día ningún candidato
que tenga el 14 o 15% que tiene maduro y
menos que tenga el 20 o 25% que tiene
digamos el chavismo como como
como partido político no O como
representación política Pero la realidad
es que si la oposición consigue
unificarse la el apoyo a la oposición es
mucho mayor que el apoyo que tiene el
chavismo mientras la posición se muestra
fracturada los cambios en la geopolítica
mundial han favorecido a Nicolás Maduro
la crisis energética por la guerra en
Ucrania el alza de los precios del
petróleo y el gas motivaron un cambio en
la política estadounidense con respecto
a Venezuela un acercamiento al gobierno
e incluso la flexibilización de algunas
sanciones además la llegada del
presidente colombiano Gustavo Petro al
poder ubicó armadura en una posición
vital para intentar alcanzar la paz con
la guerrilla del eln
Aunque maduro Ha logrado recuperar su
espacio en la arena internacional
estadistas coinciden en que a lo interno
no ha mejorado su popularidad la crisis
en materia económica y social sigue
siendo una realidad que afecta a la
mayor parte de la población
para estas elecciones del 2024 el
gobierno Está tratando de llegar lo más
fuerte posible no por eso es que está
tratando de crear una burbuja esa
sensación de que hay mejoría sobre todo
para activar a su voto duro es muy
difícil que logre pescar el voto de
fuera de lo que es su su porcentaje
fuera de lo que es ese 28
29%, el gobierno va a seguir trabajando
en ese sentido el gobierno ha puesto
sobre la mesa la posibilidad de
modificar el Consejo Nacional electoral
previo a las presidenciales para tener
un árbitro más controlado lo que podría
generar mayor desconfianza y desmotivar
el voto entre los opositores
un acuerdo del año pasado que fue un
consejo nacional electoral que le dio un
par de rectores a dos partidos de
oposición y algunas ongs está hoy de
nuevo amenazado ante la posibilidad
cierta de que vuelva a modificarse
consejo nacional electoral para
incorporar actores que vienen de esas
oposiciones cooptadas Entonces ya tú
tienes por ejemplo una situación en
donde tú decías bueno estoy tranquilo ya
lo puedes perder
la posibilidad de un acuerdo electoral
en la mesa de diálogo entre la oposición
y el gobierno en México luce lejana la
delegación de maduro condicionó
continuar con el proceso a la entrega de
los 3.200 millones de dólares en fondos
bloqueados como parte del acuerdo social
que se firmó en la última reunión de
noviembre de 2022 analistas coinciden en
que la oposición venezolana se encuentra
en su peor momento consideran que la
estrategia del gobierno de fracturar y
dividir a sus adversarios funcionó pero
también coinciden En que si logra crear
un referente unitario y conectar con los
verdaderos problemas de los ciudadanos
podrían vencer al gobierno en las urnas
la posibilidad de adelantar las
elecciones presidenciales creen no es
conveniente para Maduro que busca
legitimidad y reconocimiento
internacional con los venideros comicios
presidenciales hasta aquí Este programa
enlace andino desde Venezuela Recuerden
que pueden sintonizarnos a través de
triple W punto punto com